-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-nominated actor,
comedian, you know from
"30 Rock"
and his work
on "Saturday Night Live."
New episodes of his show,
"The Last O.G."
air Tuesday nights on TBS.
Please welcome back to the show
our very good friend
Tracy Morgan.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Tracy Morgan!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What up, what up,
what up, Seth?
Roy, Roy!
[ Laughter ]
What up, Roy?
-Yo! What's up?
-Can I get my $10 back?
[ Laughter ]
-[ Grunts ]
-You owe me $10.
-Now, last I saw you,
we Zoomed two weeks
into the pandemic,
and I got to tell you, Tracy,
I think it was the first time
I laughed
after the pandemic started.
You were so funny,
and it's so good to see you.
How are you feeling these days?
-I'm feeling great.
I'm just a little distressed.
'Cause my name --
My name keeps coming up
and everything, man.
-How so?
-They stormed the Capitol,
my name came up.
-How so?
-Michelle Obama get pregnant,
my name come up.
[ Laughter ]
Two girls and a cup,
my name come up.
-Really?
-Yeah!
-That's good!
You're in the zeitgeist.
-Man, my name keep coming up
in everything.
-Yeah.
I want to talk about
show business with you,
as I always do,
but I also want to talk about
some things that I also know
are important to you.
Inflation --
Inflation and the economy.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm gonna keep my eye on them.
-Yeah, keep your eye on them.
[ Laughter ]
-Do you have any --
-Inflation is crazy.
-Yeah, what about --
-Prices are going up
through the roof, man.
I just got some sound, good
advice for my financial adviser.
He said, "You should wait
at least a year
before you get hit
by another Walmart truck."
-Got it.
[ Laughter ]
-At least one year.
And I listened to him.
I gotta listen.
I'm going for Amazon now,
though.
-Oh, interesting.
That's good idea.
-I'm going big now, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-What about labor shortages?
Have you seen this in your life?
-Yeah, labor shortages.
They out there, man.
I went to the strip club,
there was only one stripper
in the whole club.
[ Laughter ]
She gave me, like,
one lap dance on 16.
The same mixtape.
[ Laughter ]
She stopped
taking her clothes off.
She said,
"You already saw my booty."
[ Laughter ]
"You don't need
to see it again."
-Very frustrating.
Did you get vaccinated?
Are you happy to be vaccinated?
-Yeah, I got vaccinated.
But it wasn't for COVID,
it was for gonorrhea.
-Oh, okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Keeping my mind
where it should be.
-I hope -- This is --
You know, we kind of
referenced it earlier.
This is a good time to be
a New York Knicks fan, Tracy.
Are you enjoying it?
-Yeah, man.
This, right here,
is a lucky log.
All the Knick fans --
I'm representing --
I'm representing the culture.
So all the Knicks --
all the Knicks, the players,
they come and rub this
for a win.
-When you go to the games,
they come over and they rub it.
-When I go to the game.
They doing good, too.
-Yeah.
-They look like
they like playing together.
I like it.
-And you bring your daughter
to the games?
-I be -- Oh, boo,
that's my Stinky Mama.
-Yeah.
-I call her Stinky Mama.
[ Laughter ]
You know, most fathers,
they gotta whistle,
and they kids come.
[ Imitates whistling ]
And the kids come.
But with her,
all I gotta do is go,
"Aaaaaaah!"
and she come running.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-"Aaaaaaaah!"
-Can you whistle, though, Tracy?
'Cause when you just said --
-Can I whistle?
-Yeah.
You said a lot of --
-Do I look like a magician?
[ Laughter ]
I don't be whistling.
Whistling for what?
"Aaaaaaah da-laaah!"
-That's way better.
-Come on.
So if we go to Disney World,
and, like,
she get lost
in all those people,
all I got to do is go, "Aaaah!"
and she come running.
-That's great.
And that must be nice
for the other families, as well.
-That's my Stinky Mama, yeah.
All the other families.
-What was your -- Halloween?
Did Megan dress up?
-Halloween is getting crazy
out there.
It's just different
than when I grew up.
I mean, these white kids
in my neighborhood,
'cause I live in the suburbs
now, since Walmart.
I live in the suburbs.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
So I live in the suburbs.
I'm watching this dude
over here.
[ Laughter ]
I live in the suburbs.
The white kids,
they like rap now.
They dressing the part.
They listening to rap
and all that.
But one of them
little white kids came up
and was trick-or-treating.
Yes, came to my house,
was a ghost.
So, I said,
"Who you supposed to be?"
He said, "I'm a ghost."
I said "Why the --"
The sheet was black.
-He was wearing a black sheet?
-A black sheet.
I said "Why the [bleep] --"
Excuse me.
-That's all right.
[ Laughter ]
-I said, "Well,
why your sheet is black?"
He said,
"'Cause I'm keeping it real."
[ Laughter ]
-What about you?
When you grew up,
what were your Halloweens like?
-My Halloween?
I didn't get dressed up
until I was 38.
[ Laughter ]
-What was it like
in your neighborhood?
-I dressed up as a cop.
I got whatever I wanted.
[ Laughter ]
I was a bag man.
I was a bad cop.
I dressed up as a bad cop.
-All right.
-I was a -- I dressed up --
What was his name?
What was the cop,
the good cop name?
What was his name?
-Serpico.
-Yeah.
I was a bad cop after him.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah, I was --
-So you were not --
you were not Frank Serpico.
-I was on "the take."
-So, you dressed up -- your --
-I would go
to illegal gambling spots
and got --
get whatever I wanted.
[ Laughter ]
At illegal gambling spots.
-Do you feel like we have
enough illegal gambling spots
in the city anymore?
-There's not enough.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm not getting paid.
-How would you get paid?
-I would go on "the take."
[ Laughter ]
I'd take bribes and everything.
I'm a bad cop.
[ Laughter ]
-I want --
-All I got to do
is pull out a phone book.
-Oh, is that --
-Hit them in the head
with the phone book.
[ Laughter ]
Get whatever you want.
-That was part of your costume?
You carry around a phone book?
-I need information.
-Yeah.
So would you say --
when you showed up dressed like
a bad cop with a phone book,
would you even say,
"Trick or treat,"
or would you just say, uh --
-"Give it up."
[ Laughter ]
I don't believe
in, "Trick or treat."
"Give it up."
[ Laughter ]
I'm getting ready
to get a tattoo on my hand.
-What's it gonna say?
-"Pay me."
-Really?
That's pretty nice.
-"Pay me."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I've got some more questions
for you.
You gonna stick around?
-I'm around. I'm here.
-We'll be right back with more
from Tracy Morgan.